vamos ahora con las noticias de la salud
de la mano de Mara Romero salamar Buen
día para usted Buenos días Ángela bien
vamos a empezar hablando sobre un
estudio de nutrición particularmente
sobre los posibles riesgos de un
edulcorante artificial y también muy
popular no muy popular muy ampliamente
usado estamos hablando del eritritol es
un endulzante que se usa para sustituir
el azúcar como vemos no el estudio se
publicó el lunes en la revista nature
medicine y tiene varias conclusiones
vamos con la principal el principal
titular diríamos y es que un nivel alto
de eritritol encontrado en el plasma de
la sangre está directamente relacionado
con un mayor nivel de incidentes
cardiovasculares hablamos por ejemplo de
ictus de ataques al corazón parte del
estudio se hizo en Estados Unidos y otro
en Europa vemos Que en ambos en ambos
grupos el indicador está por encima de
uno uno siendo el neutral indicaría que
no hay ninguna relación ni positiva ni
negativa ambos están por encima del uno
Eso significa que más eritritol más
incidentes cardiovasculares No es la
única parte el estudio que hicieron
también por ejemplo hicieron estudios in
vitro es decir que cogieron sangre y
plasma en el laboratorio le agregaron
este edulcorante y vieron por ejemplo
que la sangre coagulaba más que había
demasiada coagulación cosa que apuntaron
que podía hacer una de las causas de
estos mayor incidencia de accidentes
cardiovasculares y luego replicaron eso
también en los ratones vieron que
sucedía lo mismo estas son por ahora las
principales conclusiones bien y Qué
implicaciones tienen esos resultados en
la vida de las personas es una
información especialmente importante
para las personas que acuden a estos
edulcorantes sustitutivos del azúcar
precisamente para evitar el azúcar no
hablamos por ejemplo de personas
diabéticas o personas que ya tienen
problemas cardiovasculares el eritritol
está presente por ejemplo en muchísimos
de los alimentos que son el light no que
se dice que están sin azúcar es el
resultado de la fermentación de varios
alcoholes que da ese edulcorante y
además está presente en varios alimentos
de forma natural también por cierto en
algunas frutas o en bebidas Como por
ejemplo el vino se calcula que 70% tan
dulce como el azúcar por eso lo hace tan
buen sustituto y también porque tiene un
conteo calórico muy bajo y un índice
glucémico muy bajo es decir que no
altera el azúcar en sangre dando igual
ese gusto dulce que muchos pues todavía
buscamos en la comida importante también
decir que los resultados de este estudio
no significan que tengamos que apartarlo
ya mismo de nuestra dieta primero porque
se apunta a una correlación no a una
causa hay un vínculo entre este
edulcorante y un mayor riesgo de
enfermedades cardiovasculares pero no se
sabe si eso puede ser directamente la
causa eso pasa mucho en nutrición que
hay tantos factores de estilo de vida de
nutrición que es muy difícil aislar
completamente Cuál es la causa segundo
Porque el estudio Podría tener algunos
sesgos por ejemplo la mayoría de
participantes eran mayores de 60 años
que hay un riesgo cardiovascular pues
mayor en esta población de adultos y
tercero porque recordemos que el
eritritol se sigue considerando un
alimento seguro por la mayoría de
agencias Pues de alimentos y de
medicaciones del mundo
y es verdad que hay un consenso en que
falta más investigación sobre este tipo
de edulcorantes sobre todo a largo plazo
sabemos que a corto plazo no son
riesgosos pero no tenemos tantos datos a
largo plazo lo que nos llama es hacer
equilibrados mar Porque además por su
bajo contenido calórico el eritritol es
muy frecuentemente consumido por las
personas que quieren hacer planes por
ejemplo de reducción de peso de mejoras
de salud ahora
en últimas los excesos son malos Esa es
la conclusión sí intentar comerlo más
equilibrado posible ahora vamos a
cambiar de tema para hablar de otro
estudio bien interesante que realizó un
análisis sobre la prevalencia del aborto
en países de ingresos medios y bajos Sí
la verdad son unas cifras muy
interesantes que se publicaron ayer es a
raíz de un análisis de datos
demográficos recogidos en encuestas de
36 países de ingresos bajos y medios se
concluyó que la prevalencia del aborto
era de un 13% más de una década 10
mujeres había accedido a una
interrupción del embarazo con
diferencias muy significativas además
entre países la cifra más baja con
7,8%, la cifra más alta era un Pakistán
34% de mujeres reportaban haber accedido
a una interrupción del embarazo Pero
quizás además unos de los datos más
interesantes son las correlaciones que
han encontrado demográficas Cuáles son
las mujeres que acceden a un aborto
hemos puesto dos ejemplos Aquí vemos
particularmente que el estudio haya que
las que más interrumpen embarazo más
acceden a un aborto son mujeres más
mayores y mujeres que están en
matrimonio y además que ya tenían uno o
más hijos
contrariamente Al que quizás podríamos
inferir que es que son mujeres jóvenes
que no tienen planeado empezar una
familia y así no entonces bueno Estos
son algunos de los datos que queríamos
dar aquí más interesantes y pues más
contrastantes también Bueno qué
interpretación podemos dar a esas cifras
que usted nos entrega pues primero hay
que reconocer que son datos auto
reportados en encuestas que eso siempre
puede implicar algún tipo de sesgo
entonces toca [__] estos datos con
precaución pero
los autores del estudio hablan por
ejemplo de factores socioeconómicos en
la mayoría de estos países analizados
que son países de Asia y de África las
mujeres casadas en estos países podrían
estar sin acceso por ejemplo a ningún
tipo de medidas anticonceptivas también
sabemos que en edades más altas hay más
riesgos de embarazo que también podría
ser uno de los factores que llevan más
riesgos al tener el embarazo quiero
decir que podrían llevar a las mujeres a
decidir interrumpirlo Especialmente
cuando ya tienen una familia formada es
importante entender Pues cómo suceden
estas dinámicas tener este tipo de datos
Porque en la mayoría de estos países de
nuevo analizados no hay un acceso al
aborto seguro el aborto no está
legalizado casi no está regulado
entonces eso significa también saber qué
mujeres acceden estas abortos son saber
qué mujeres están poniendo en riesgo al
acceder a abortos que no son seguros una
de las principales causas además de
muerte materna en el mundo ese es otro
problema de penalizar El aborto mar y no
nos hemos cansado de repetirlo en France
24 que las maternidades tienen que ser
deseadas y no puede ser que somos
fábricas de bebés y bien un hijo el otro
el otro el otro y pues asumir tres o
cuatro maternidades
es durísimo y además es muy duro para el
cuerpo para la salud de las mujeres que
son quienes asumen al final de estos
cambios a la hora de tener hijos y las
tareas de Cuidado así